Hello world and hello
people of Native Lang.
I'm Jessica from comp Tom and I'm so
excited to be a guest here talking about
the intersection between
language and code.
I'm also really excited to be
here at Youtube Space New York.
There are amazing cameras.
The super talented crew.
You even get to see me dance can
laugh at it. Comment. All right,
let's get down to business and find
out if computer languages even count as
languages.
I think their new spoiler alert.
I am so jealous right now.
I just found out that 10th graders like
Sally are gonna Start getting foreign
language credit for learning to
program games on their iPhones.
No slugging through years of conjugating
Sarah and a star like I had to do.
But you know Sally's mom,
she's a,
she's a bit iffier about this because
she says that programming languages with
all the curly braces and weird semi
colons and strange Matthew symbols are
nothing like a foreign language.
Is She right?
Is Matthew looking code like
this really a language language.
Yeah.
Welcome to come chomp the only show on
the Internet where we crack jokes in
binary zero one one zero one one
zero m zero one don't get me wrong.
I actually really enjoyed my
time in high school Spanish.
Maybe don't ask me to order a meal when
we're out because you were most likely
going to get the Cabeza.
They cheapo. Sorry.
Now I'm a programmer and I get to look
back and wonder what I was learning
Spanish. Was I really doing
anything different than
when I was learning to code?
I mean in my code I use words.
I use syntax to put those words together
and I even use related languages and
dialects. Oh, that's right. In
programming, there are language dialects.
It all sounds so languagey,
but does it look languagey facts alert.
Woo.
You know it's going to be good facts
because these are my good facts. Glasses,
if you want it to.
How do you think you could tell whether
learning to program was like learning a
foreign language.
You could round up a bunch of programmers
and just shove them into an MRI and
scan their brains while
they're reading code.
And that is exactly what
Yanet Sigmund and team did.
Trudeau is guys,
actually no,
I'm a programmer and I really hate in
close spaces. Don't put me in there.
So let's say that you're a coder and
you're holed up in an MRI machine and they
show you this. What does it mean?
Well let's read it together.
I'm a program stick label Var one on the
number 23 and another label of our two
on the number 42 now pull out a label
temp, but don't put it anywhere just yet.
Now take temp and stick it where of our
one is then PLF var one and stick it
over there with bar too. And you can now
take far too and put it backward temp.
After this whole run around, which
number did our label var would end up on.
That's right. We switched them. All
right, this, this is kind of fun.
I like reading code. Let's do
another one. I'm a program too.
So this is auto.
Who wears the name tag word.
Give me a switch to flip when I get the
right answer and give that switched the
name tag result.
Start one counter counting up from zero
and another one counting down from the
end of the word as the first counter
counts up and the second counter counts
down, you go until you reach
the middle of the word.
And at each count compare the two
letters and if they are the same,
keep going.
But if they're different,
flip that results which to false and
stop doing everything you're done.
Just tell us whether
result is true or false.
Did you figure out what this did yet?
Come on. I know one of you language guys.
Has it figured out?
We just checked if auto is a palindrome.
And for those of you that aren't sure,
auto is,
so what type of brain patterns do you
think lit up when coders were reading code
like this?
Probably just the ones that deal
with math right or totally wrong.
It's the ones that deal
with language and memory.
Basically being a fluent coder looks a
whole lot like being a native speaker.
One, two punch. It's my upper
cut or I don't know my job.
Go out right now and demand
foreign language credits
for your programming smarts.
If your goal is to teach someone
to think in a new language,
you pretty much can't go wrong with
programming unless you're teaching basic.
You need to stop teaching the kids basic.
It is not a good idea.
Details to come later,
tragic traumatic details,
but you know,
if your goal is to have a whole cultural
experience to read Don Quixote and
accidentally ordered the visitee Chico,
it's not really something you
can do and see. All right,
I hope you'll spend a few more videos
with this program are talking language.
I'm Jessica from comp champ.
Subscribe for more about how code is
part of your everyday life and hanging
around here on native Leng where we're
doing a short series of videos together
about the awesome overlap
between code and language chunk.